welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital images part
three bitmaps versus objects so in the
previous videos what we've been focusing
on
is how the computer display actually
works
what we're going to do now is we're
going to switch gears slightly and we're
going to take a look at
how images are actually stored on the
computer so
the difference being how does the
hardware work versus
how do files that we want to use in
order to store our images work
and it turns out there's two fundamental
ways we can store an image in a file
the first method is very similar to what
we've seen previously
in terms of how the computer display
works so as we saw the computer display
each of the individual pixels
has either a single bit backing it if we
have a black and white image
or a set of bits or bytes behind it if
we have a color image so we saw there
was 24-bit color
where each individual pixel has 24 bits
behind it and we saw a 32-bit color
and so what we can do is we can just
store
each of those individual pixel values
and store them in a file
so here's here's an image here and
suppose we wanted to store this
in a file we're going to start off with
our bitmap representation which matches
how the display works and you can see
what we've done is we've got all the
individual pixel values here and we're
just going to store each of individually
so i can say oh
well in the top left hand corner i have
pixel 0 0 and that is rgb 255
255 255 which means red green and blue
are at maximum which means we're going
to have white
and i can store the value for the next
pixel over
pixel one zero and that is also rgb 255
255 255 and so on
we go down a couple rows we're going to
store each of the individual pixels in
each of these rows
we go down a couple rows we get to that
top of that circle there and you can see
oh well pixel 9 4 meaning
x equals 9 y equals 4 9 from the left
4 from the top that's still white rgb
255 255 255 but then we go to the next
one
pixel 10 4 and this one's actually red
so rgb is 255
0 and 0 and so on and then we can keep
on going
uh filling in all these individual pixel
values sooner or later we're going to
get to the
rectangle there and you can see that the
rectangle you know we've got
right before the rectangle this is line
21.
this is y equals 12 x equals 21
that one's still white rgb 255 255 255.
we get to the next pixel over x equals
y equals 12. and then this one's a
different color so
you can see that this is mostly blue
blues 247 but there's some red and green
in there
red 87 green 84
blue 247 and then i store the next pixel
over that one's the same color and so on
and i just
store all the individual pixel values
one after the other
now this definitely works
this matches exactly how the display is
working but
there are other ways to store the same
information
so this particular representation again
is referred to as bitmap or raster
graphics we're going to take a look at
another way of representing the
information
this next way of representing the
information is what we refer to as
object
or sometimes referred to as vector
graphics and you can see here we've got
the exact same image
but we're going to instead of storing
all the individual pixel values we're
going to think of these as geometric
shapes so i can think
oh i've got a circle here's the x and y
coordinates for the center
the radius is 8 pixels the stroke which
is the width of the pen color is one
pixel
and the stroke color is actually red rgb
255 no green and no blue
and then i've got my rectangle i go
ahead and start the xy location in the
top left-hand corner
i go ahead and store the width and
height and then i go ahead and store the
fill color
and you can see that this also stores
the exact same image but it stored the
image in a different way
so fundamentally we have these two
choices do i want to store something as
a bitmap
again also known as raster or do i want
to store things as objects
also sometimes referred to as vector
graphics so what we're going to do now
is we're going to take a look at the
advantages and disadvantages these
of these two approaches okay so the
first thing we're going to compare is
how much space do these two methods take
so what we've got here is on our left
we're going to
to try and estimate how much space our
little image here took
when we're storing things as a bitmap
with 24-bit color we need to store
three bytes for each of the individual
pixels in the image
now this image here is actually around
64 pixels by 48 pixels
i know it looks much larger but that's
because i magnified everything so we can
get a closer look at everything
when you multiply 3 bytes by 64 by 48
pixels
you end up with just a little over 9000
bytes
now let's take a look at how much space
we need for our objects
well it's going to depend upon each of
the individual
values we're going to store for each of
our objects so for example we're storing
the center
and we're going to start an x and y
value how large are those x y values are
they one bite each
you know we might store more more
attributes for
our rectangle than for our circle you
know in this case are we allowing people
to change both the
outer color or the stroke color as well
as the fill color
and so the actual amount of space
that each of these objects is going to
take is going to vary but
i estimate we need about 8 to 12 bytes
per object
assuming that the that the image that
we're storing it on is relatively small
if it's a much larger image we would
need to store
larger values for our x and y um so
it it really is going to vary a bit in
this particular case i'm saying we need
about 8 to 12 bytes per object
in this particular image i only have two
objects and so you can see that will
take 16 to 24 bytes
so it's really not much of a comparison
in one case for
objects i've got 16 to 24 bytes and with
the bitmaps we've got
9216 bytes so you can see that the clear
winner here
is storing things as our
vector or object graphics
all right the next thing i want to look
at is
what happens when we've got an image
using one of these two techniques and we
go ahead and zoom in
so what i've got is we're going to take
a look at two different programs
we're going to start with our bitmap
representation and so
what we're looking at here is this is
microsoft paint it's a standard painting
program that's included with microsoft
windows
i'm drawing a couple different objects
here
and then i'm zooming in and the main
thing to be looking for here is
notice as i zoom in things start looking
kind of jagged
and so what's happening here is when i
zoom in
i'm not getting more pixels what's
happening is the pixels
in the bitmap representation are just
being displayed as larger and larger and
larger so they're getting very jagged
all right so this next program is adobe
animate which is
the animation program i've used for some
of the simple animations in this class
and so again i'm going to draw a couple
different objects here
and now i'm going to zoom in and you can
see that if i increase the zoom level
sorry i'm laughing here you can hear
maddie playing with her
squeak toy sorry as i
zoom in here uh you can see that
the that i can zoom in as far as i want
and there's no sign of those jagged
edges so what's happening here is
with the object slash vector graphic
approach
i've actually got a mathematical formula
and i can recalculate
as i move tighter and tighter and closer
and closer in
i can just use that formula and i can
recalculate where things need to be
and i can zoom in as far as i want and
that
geometric shape is still going to look
picture perfect
so what i like to talk about now is
when we're looking at these two possible
representations what is our ability
to edit or manipulate a document after
that document has been created so we're
going to start off with our bitmap
representation again and again this is
microsoft paint
you can see i've got a number of
different objects i've drawn here
in my document and if i try and
edit this document what we're going to
discover is that i cannot edit the
individual
shapes here so you know i've got a
circle or a rectangle drawn
once i've drawn those objects on
the screen once i put those into my
document
they are no longer considered individual
geometric shapes instead what the
program thinks of them as
as just hey here's a bunch of pixels
these pixels are particular colors
they aren't part of a geometric shape
once
i've completed drawing them so when i'm
manipulating this document
i can only manipulate individual pixels
or groups of pixels i can't manipulate
the original circles or lines or squares
now this next application this is adobe
illustrator
this is a program that's designed for
object or vector drawing and so you can
see i can go ahead and grab these
individual shapes
i can rotate them i can change their
colors i can change their sizes
with the object or vector graphic
representation
these individual shapes on the screen
are thought of as geometric shapes and i
can go ahead and manipulate them as
geometric shapes so that's in pretty
sharp contrast with our bitmap
representation
okay so at this point you may be
thinking boy this
vector object thing sounds way way
better than the bitmap raster
representation why would i ever want to
use bitmap raster well
here's the thing there are things that
you simply cannot represent with
mathematical formulas so here's
here's a photograph of maddie she's uh
she's checking my computer out here
and you know there are parts of this
image that we might be able to come up
with some geometric shapes to represent
so the computer for example maybe we
could represent that as a geometric
shape but
you know what about maddie's fur that's
just not
not gonna happen so
we can't come up with a mathematical
formula that's going to represent each
of her
individual fur follicles and so
when we're looking at a photograph
something that we've taken with a camera
that's going to be represented as a
bitmap if we're generating something
from scratch in our head like some sort
of a diagram or
some sort of a logo or some sort of a
graphic then
you know that's a great time to take
advantage of the vector object
representation so you know use the
vector object representation when you
can but be aware that there's a lot of
cases
where you simply need to use bitmap so
you know digital painting photographs
these are all things that can't really
be represented with
with the vector object approach